The fellow scholars,
this is two minute papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. This paper fixes
many common problems when it comes to two-way coupling in fluid simulations.
And of course, the first question is what is two-way coupling?
It means that here the boxes are allowed to move the smoke and the added
two way coupling part means that now the smoke is also allowed to blow away
the boxes. What's more,
the vorticies here on the right are even able to suspend the red box in the air
for a few seconds, an excellent demonstration of a beautiful phenomenon.
However,
simulating this effect properly for water simulations and for GUI materials
is a huge challenge. So let's see how traditional methods deal with them.
Experiment. Number one, water bunnies.
And do you see what I am seeing here? Immediacy the magic trick.
Let's look again.
Observe how much water we are starting with a full bunny worth of water.
And then by the end, we have maybe a quarter of a bunny left.
Oh yes.
We have a substantial amount of numerical dissipation in the simulator that
leads to volume loss. Can this be solved somehow? Well,
let's see how this no work deals with us starting with one bunny
and ending it with one bunny. Nice.
Just look at the difference of the volume of water left with the new method
compared to the previous one night and day difference.
And this was not even the worst volume loss I've seen.
Make sure to hold onto your papers and check out this one.
Experiment. Number two,
gooey dragons and balls when using a traditional technique, Whoa,
this guy is gone. And when we try a different method,
it does this my goodness.
So let's see if the new method can deal with this case.
Oh yes, yes it can. And now onwards to experiment.
Number three,
if you think that research is about throwing things at the wall and seeing what
sticks in the case of the scene, you are not wrong.
So what should happen here, given these materials? Well,
the bunny should stick to the goal and not fall too quickly.
Hmm. None of which happens here.
The previous method does not seem late viscosity properly.
And hence this artificial mounting phenomenon emerges.
I wonder if the new method can do this too. And
yes,
they stick together and the Google correctly slows down the fall of the bunny.
So how does this magic work? Normally in these simulations,
we have to compute pressure viscosity and frictional contact separately,
which are three different tasks.
The technique described in the paper is called monolith because it has a
monolithic pressure viscosity contact solver. Yes.
This means that he does all three of these tasks in one goal,
which is mathematically a tiny bit more involved,
but it gives us a proper simulator where water and Google can interact
with solids, no volume loss, no artificial melting,
no crazy jumpy behavior. And here comes the punchline.
I was thinking that, all right,
the more accurate simulator that is always welcome,
but what is the price of this accuracy?
How much longer do I have to wait if you have been holding onto your papers
now squeeze that paper because this technique is not slower,
but up to 10 times faster than previous methods.
And that's where I fell off the chair. When reading this paper and with this,
I hope that we will be able to Marvel at even more delightful, two way,
couple of simulations in the near future. What a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by weights and biases in this post.
They show you how you can get an email or Slack notification.
When your model crashes with this,
you can check on your model performance on any device,
heavenly weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your
deep learning project.
Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that weights and biases is free for all individuals
academics and open source project. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wnb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get the free demo today.
Our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.